hoy el parque más famoso de la ciudad de
Nueva York este en el que nos
encontramos Central Park cumple 60 años
desde que se declaró monumento nacional
aquí lo conocemos como el pulmón verde
de Manhattan y viendo la estampa que hay
detrás de mí se pueden imaginar el
porqué estamos hablando de cuatro
kilómetros de parque a lo largo y 800
metros a los ancho a lo ancho pura
naturaleza en medio de la famosa ciudad
de los rascacielos un parque histórico
icónico que hemos visto muchísimas veces
en las películas de Hollywood y que su
construcción no fue nada fácil los
planos por fin Se cerraron después de
muchos cambios y muchas
reconsideraciones en 1873 pero no fue
hasta 1963 cuando se declaró un lugar
histórico de los Estados Unidos y eso
básicamente lo que hace es proteger lo
que aquí no se construya y que esos
edificios que hay alrededor nos sigan
avanzando Y acaben con el parque un
parque en el que hay más de 18
.000 árboles por los que corren 2500
ardillas con las que se fotografían esos
25 millones de turistas que pasan por
aquí cada año hoy como ven hay bastante
gente es el primer día que hace
realmente tiempo para salir al parque y
qué mejor motivo para disfrutarlo que 60
cumpleaños en un día tan importante
histórico para este parque más famoso de
Nueva York el central